uh balloting is underway on the fifth
and final day of referendums in
separatist held regions of Ukraine votes
on whether to join Russia are being held
in four areas under Russian military
occupation they include the
self-declared Donetsk and the Hansen
republics in the East and her son and
his upper Asia in the South Kiev and the
Western allies say the votes are a sham
orchestrated by Russia Moscow says any
annexed areas will be under its full
protection
well let's get latest from Charles
Stratford in cave so Charles are these
referendums continuing despite the
ongoing War
that's right the final day of these
referenda described by Ukraine its
allies and the UN as being a complete
illegitimate illegal sham
um it's very difficult to get obviously
verifiable information and to look at
verifiable pictures coming out of these
Russian occupied areas where these votes
are ongoing um over the last couple of
days we've been trying to Source
materials certainly pro-russian media
very keen to tell what they say is
obviously a fair and free election going
on there but it's been very interesting
looking at some of the interviews that
have been aired
many of the people as you can expect
being interviewed saying that they are
for Russia but many many people refusing
to speak on camera
many people looking very nervous about
being interviewed we understand
certainly according to Ukrainian
authorities that around in the lugansk
region alone which is pretty much fully
occupied by Russia there are around 350
000 ukrainians still living there now of
course hundreds of thousands of
civilians left when the war started and
have left prior to that actually during
the eight years of of conflict with
russian-backed separatists and certainly
the authorities the Ukrainian
authorities that we've spoken to here we
spoke to yesterday the head of the
regional military Administration a
gentleman called Sergey Heyday he says
that these what he describes as a legal
referenda have absolutely zero impact on
the Ukraine's military strategy
he appealed to ukrainians in those areas
and said it's uh that they should move
away from what he said were military
sites he said that the campaign would
continue he said that Ukraine would be
furthering its pressure on the European
Union and its NATO allies to to increase
sanctions on Russia his comments with
respect to this partial mobilization as
the Russian leader of Vladimir Putin
described it
um this uh this gentleman saying that
this again had no impact whatsoever he
said that we destroyed the regular
Russian army and now we will destroy its
irregular one its un professional one he
described these men as being cannon
fodder for Ukrainian guns meanwhile
fighting continues in various regions
we're hearing of Rocket attacks
overnight on the town of mikolayev in
the South also an area to the north of
that an area called bus stand Ukrainian
authorities saying that they took down
overnight what they say were at least
two maybe three Iranian drones being
used by the Russians to attack Odessa
and we also know that there is ongoing
fighting around the uh the city of
Donetsk and The Wider region and what
the Ukrainian authorities are saying is
that this referenda no matter it taking
place no matter this mobilization of
more Russian forces into this area
they're expecting even more heavy
fighting in the days and weeks to come
so I'll start for Life for Us in Kiev
thank you